so this is an old episode that pod boy
who now is vindictive with these people
which I love I don't [ __ ] strike
people
um this is
all right
this is a deleted episode of his show
you ready
this is bad
this is [ __ ] bad who's this guy in
the bottom right
do we know someone will tell us right
show more
I don't know do you know this guy is
Marsh uh uh by any chance
uh he looks familiar right anyway it
doesn't matter watch you went to Cuba I
went to Cuba that's right and you can't
go to Cuba without
having it turned into a total like [ __ ]
mongering does a [ __ ] yeah you can no
you can it's called it's called
self-control yeah
it's called a family vacation I'm not
saying you can't go to Cuba and even
like get a prostitute fine but if you do
you need how many do you need remember
we watched the video of like the dude
that went to Cube and he was just buying
them with shirts yeah like don't even
ask for money they're so poor there you
go with FUBU shirt like oh [ __ ] you you
know it's predatory sir yes well
little like [ __ ] mongering just a [ __ ]
fest now I'm sure these women that you
did were over the age of 18. all of them
come on man
uh
so
all of them and by all I mean
it turned into a total like [ __ ]
mongering does a [ __ ] fest no I'm sure
these women that you did were over the
age of 18. all of them
we have cameras so that face doesn't
mean anything
all of them all of them all of them
correct all of them look at it right now
all of them correct every single one all
eighteen and the other thing is like
every girl that went into the house she
had to give her
her uh papers to the woman I mean I when
I was
I know I'm gonna be very careful careful
what the [ __ ] dude
owes bro yo oh my God she knows some
skeletons in this motherfucker's closet
she ain't going nowhere
that's why she owns the company
yeah now you want to know why she owns
the company
wow
woman I mean I when I was oh I'm gonna
be very careful but my question is this
I'm not gonna go into that story there
are certain countries where it's not
yeah she just saved my career baby thank
you so much you're welcome nothing
happened but I'm just saying you know
what I mean nothing my mom would be crap
my mom would be crying right now if she
heard this
dude something a key I'm not gonna go
into that story and she's just like
she looks so put what did he do
she looks like she knows the story I
mean is this the Opie and Anthony story
he told
I think it's a different story well I
know that one but I mean it may have did
who knows it might be a different one
Jesus
they're all such sick
everybody in that [ __ ] state that
whole place is just cancerous
that's uh
it's Bobby Lee oh and then this sorry
is that yeah totally oh what do you mean
what's the history this is I'm taking
the words out of your mouth well I never
said that
oh God when did I say that
oh God what this is where I'm gonna
expose you in two seconds expose expose
away expose away I have no idea what you
mean by that
[Music]
I'm hoping indoors I want to be exposed
oftentimes in this podcast oftentimes in
this podcast
I will take what you've said and make it
my own because it's a little bit too
inflammatory but anyway
a little bit too inflammatory oh [ __ ]
yeah right yeah yeah like I know okay
I'll see you want me to expose you or
not wait wait hold on hold on hold on so
she's saying guys so she's saying that
sometimes she says she does stuff but
it's actually Bobby who did it but
she'll say she did it so it comes off
Morris like it's she's a doctor she's a
dumb girl is that I mean is that what
she's implying I mean Bobby jerked off
the dog Bobby slept with his family
member
it's that's that's what she's putting on
the [ __ ] table
s here right now as a possibility
anyways
oh I'd like black pod boy or pod boy pod
Boy Is Awesome with these yeah let me
give them credit [ __ ] fire curly hair
yeah right and then
yeah
no I was gonna see some racist stuff and
I just edited myself fantastic and
that's growth for me wow what about this
is no but let me listen this podcast is
a safe place for unsafe thoughts I don't
mean this say it all you want what I was
gonna say is black skin right okay afro
my hair right and I wasn't just dip my
hands in oil I have oily skin they're
not naturally oily
um
depends dry cocoa butter yeah is it yeah
they're not always oily yeah
Bobby goes on to Michael rosenbaum's
podcast it opens up about being
blackmailed now this is where it gets
fun last year oh [ __ ] I get a call going
you got a commercial campaign with
Jordan peel Chelsea Peretti and Jane
Lynch but then at the same time I was
getting emails because of tigerbelly
from an African-American woman extorting
money from me
she was like you said this about black
people and then I said one thing and I
said now I said that black people were
sometimes oily
that's all I said sometimes Jews are
oily right right now I know this
interview well
oily and sleazy are close to this
conversation's making me oily yeah yeah
did it make you oily with now the person
you don't call a friend but they used to
be your friend that was a Nexium
remember the woman walked into his house
oh that's a rose bomb guy yeah from
Smallville right yeah that's right I
know I barely knew her yeah you guys
weren't all [ __ ] on you weren't
[ __ ] all these young actresses on
yeah okay
and so then she goes I'm gonna blast
this out I'm gonna go to Every media
Outlet if you don't send me fifteen
thousand dollars did you send it to her
no of course not it's [ __ ]
blackmailing extortion right so no I'm
on sat with I'm doing a scene with John
Jane Lynch I'm gonna I'm on our bed I've
seen that you make it out make out with
her so I'm laying there and then these
two lawyers come up to me and they go
can we pull you up to the side come on
yeah [ __ ] we just wanna let you know
that we got a complaint from this lady
who said you said this is something
racist or whatever
that's a good point that's a good point
how did they know he was doing a
commercial before it aired
and I have the person find the contact
in for the production company I I could
have cried blood I was so angry the next
day I call everyone my lawyer everybody
and we sent her letters you know like
stop this yeah but ever since then like
I've been editing and stuff so you're
scared from that one thing you said
you're sort of altering or changing some
things that you do normally yeah
for
you know that person you know that
listen to this podcast that try to um
yeah interesting that person's a [ __ ]
loser it's so weird how he still
comments and like I know who this person
is too like this person thinks I don't
know but I've done my [ __ ] Recon on
you baby
La you're [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sorry I
can't I know I should try to like but
she's just
hey she's so stupid
and and I don't know how somebody could
be so manipulative and so stupid at the
same time yeah it is odd I did my
reasons yeah I could just copy paste the
thing in a Google and search the name
like you're not really [ __ ] doing
your recon yeah you're a Machiavellian
[ __ ] exactly NSA you don't even
[ __ ] know I guess she had a YouTube
video of me with the a with a um Clan
outfit
[Music]
tell Bobby to talk about the video
all of you
people when they get extorted because we
don't give a [ __ ] we say what the [ __ ]
we want you're gonna go oh tell somebody
like Tom I don't care go [ __ ] what do I
care you people are so coddled and you
buy into all your little therapist talk
over there that now you're afraid you're
not gonna have a commercial gig all
right I've already had so many hit
squads and [ __ ] hit pieces and
[ __ ] people throwing the kitchen
sinking me I don't give a [ __ ] and
here's the other thing that I think is
important to point out what was worse
Bobby I in the long run what was worse
somebody extorting you because you were
racist on a podcast for a commercial
or the [ __ ] to your right who told you
not to take a [ __ ] Netflix movie with
Jamie Foxx because she didn't want you
to do the ching chong voice yeah but how
big is the deal is Jamie Foxx well I
know you get residual checks from
Netflix
that's what I know what was worse for
your career
I don't we don't give him or her or it
no it's a him is it but I know but I
should I've shown it to every black
person that I know and we just laugh
all right so the two guys that are that
are on fighter and the kid but like who
else do you know
who did you wear a Phil Lamar
Phil Lamar well he he was on Mad TV
really good reference though it was on
Mad TV Bill Lamar
like 100 people and we just giggle like
you have a hundred black friends
then the Bobby must have been poorly
made maybe embarrassing this person try
to create a video of Bobby with a Ku
Klux Klan um a hat
Kenneth are you that person that dude is
doing this are you this person let me
tell you something right now I know but
listen to me right now Simone the person
is doing it I'm not gonna give away who
it is but it was easy to find out what
it was it was
thick boy thick boy 69 fighter wait a
minute I I have two suspects how many
C's three C's probably there's three C's
probably one man there's only one man it
could be and it ain't Tom Segura
or Burke Chrysler which one is it with a
thick Boy shirt I don't can't keep up
they look the same to me I'm not trying
to be racist I'm just saying